pay attention listen up we have  everything we need but we need these two  guys right here all right our defense  needs to land is so hard trying to get  this big deal Martin oh I understand but  that's why you're not doing that's why  I'm doing have you seen the news yes  I've seen a mic on your boat look at me  let's go it  you can go go  heyo I am a coward  [Music]  got smell get in here  and warning  they're happy so  I'm coming for you  [Applause]  so go Oh what is y'all doing bro don't  even say anything  hey are you ready to turn this thing  around man I just want to go home let us  out  Brad shut up both y'all just answer the  questions let us go  all right bad welcome home boys  [Music]